hey guys when it was just it is Monday
today and you're watching games bunyan a
new update for the witcher 3 is arriving
tomorrow to coincide with the launch of
the game of the year edition if you go
out and buy the game of the year edition
you won't need to install the update as
it comes pre-loaded 1.3 patch isn't the
largest the game has had so far but it
does include a bunch of updates and
improvements the patch includes a
character update for the dwarf Bank
Irving Vivaldi multiple bug fixes enemy
balancing and updates to the graphics
user interface the game of the year
edition is selling for 50 bucks and
includes the base game all DLC and the
hearts of stone and blood and wine
expansions Microsoft has announced
they've started sending out the first
player designed custom xbox one
controllers the personalized controllers
from xboxes design lab are now beginning
to ship and are expected to arrive to
their new homes in September the
publisher explained in an xbox wire
statement that they've seen a tremendous
amount of interest and excitement from
people keen on the controllers since
they were announced in June Microsoft
pulled some no man's sky style math and
have said there are 8 million possible
color combinations you can also drop
another 10 bucks to get your gamertag or
something offensive engraved on the back
the controllers are selling for 80 bucks
and are currently only available in the
US Canada and Puerto Rico although
they're expected to come to other
markets in 2017 they're based on the new
model of xbox one controllers that are
shipping with the Xbox one s feature
Bluetooth connectivity and textured
grips and they work on xbox one Xbox one
s and PC Final Fantasy 15 director
Hajime Tabata has further explained why
the game is coming later than expected
after announcing a delay from sep tember
to november to barter told japanese
publication for mitsui the optimization
isn't sufficient yet explaining there
are various bugs throughout the game and
the frame rate isn't holding to its 30
frames per second target as consistently
as Square Enix would like Tabata went on
to say there are still a number of bugs
like characters floating on that
the air or appearing all strange and
glitchy he added that the extra dev time
will also be used to refine the game
balance which you'll need to interpret
for yourself because he didn't go into
any more details on that one Tabata also
restated that another of the major
reasons for the delay is to avoid the
necessity for a day one patch as not
everyone's consoles connected to the
Internet Tabata apologize for the delay
but said it was the right move to help
quote achieve a level of perfection that
our fans deserve head to games what the
story's gonna watch dogs two and a new
3ds XL design and I will see you again
tomorrow